nice lineup of speakers if you're on
Zoom uh please yell out your question if
you have a question we're not monitoring
chat
um our first speaker is Adam kalai of
Microsoft tell us about succinct neural
networks great
um so yeah I'm excited to be here and
talk about this is Joint work with uh
survey goel who's now at Penn and Sean
krakade who's at Harvard and Cyril Zhang
who's at Microsoft research in New York
and this is a paper with a long title uh
but I think I shortened it for this talk
uh to make it more succinct and so I'll
tell you about succinct neural networks
what they are and uh how you can use
them to learn interesting classes of
functions and so let me just jump right
in
um and please please interrupt with
questions I'd rather have a discussion
and not finish all the slides then
all right so
um there's a lot of excitement about
neural Nets and true all I wear and one
of the things they're not great at is
learning algorithms
um they're okay but they're they're you
know great at learning human-like data
but they don't seem to be amazing at
learning how to multiply numbers things
like that that's their natural strength
um so here's an example of a function
you know there's the line spinach up
here but there's um
you know the X's are on the the left
here and the Y's are on the right and
the function is to learn which you're
given the two inputs uh which are
numbers and your goal is let's say to
learn which number has more sevens okay
and just output that number there's just
some random function here there's an
example and you know that's a trivial
kind of learning problem for a human
um
and uh just to mention you know uh
there's this uh classic I guess you'd
call it a folk theorem for learning
which is that you can learn any kind of
thing which could be computed by a short
program
um that runs quickly and basically you
can enumerate all programs which is kind
of silly but um you could do it in
principle and you could find a function
uh that Maps each input x i to the
output y i and then when you find one
that uh you know Works in enough
examples you output at that and uh that
will you can give prove guarantees that
that will work well
um so that's sort of the monkey of the
typewriter style of learning
um and uh it's kind of it seems kind of
ridiculous but actually nowadays you can
kind of replace it by uh by by GPT or
some large language model and you can
actually get it to do things like this a
little bit so this is just this is
actually not really like Central to my
talk but I just want to throw that out
it's kind of an interesting twist for
people to think about taking their
Theory things which use enumeration and
imagine replacing it with a more
intelligent uh you know language model
like GPT or something so
um you can actually type into uh these
days there's a system called copilot
where you as you're programming it calls
GPT and tries to finish a code for you
so if you say let's call it let's define
a function called more sevens it will
put some code here which is wrong but
it's pretty it's correct code at least
it's much better than just enumerating
chewing machines but actually if you
give it the examples I have here and
then you say you know here here are
these examples and here's the function
more sevens it will actually give you
pretty much correct code uh exactly for
this so way better than the numerating
terms
um
okay and you know you could do it uh
just to mention here because uh you know
it doesn't even have to be an efficient
a problem that's in P you could ask for
you know find the smallest factor of a
number smallest prime factor uh which
you know we don't know how to do quickly
but you know an average maybe we can do
it quickly on the inputs that we get or
most of them because most most numbers
have small factors so it um this same
approach will work even if the problem
is not uh perfectly solvable in pu can
still do pretty well
um Let me throw out another type of
example which this won't work for which
is I say learning a parity function in
the case of learning a parity function
so the input is some vector and N
dimensions of zero ones and there's some
secret Vector W of zeros and ones and
the the labels here are the inner
product mod too
um so this won't work because
um the monkey or GPT would have to guess
basically if it doesn't see these
examples as it would it would have to
guess just in rates and have to
enumerate the secret W which is in bit
so it would be exponentially unlikely so
this approach would be uh wouldn't work
it works for constant size during
machines but not for larger ones
foreign
so all right so
um let me tell you what succinct neural
networks are first in analogy so uh deep
neural networks are there's supposed to
be edges here deep neural networks are
like circuits succinct neural networks
are like Turing machines okay
um
uh so how does that work so I'll turn
the picture on the side so I'll put the
inputs on the left here and basically
you've got this succinct Network here
that let's say takes uh let's say it
takes three inputs okay and produces one
output and this is going to be a
constant size neural network you could
think of it like a circuit as well it's
a constant size neural network we'll
call it s and it takes three inputs and
produces one output and you'll see why
three and one in the second and uh the
inputs are
scattered over here and we'll pad them
with a negative one in the top and the
bottom and again this uh this network is
small size
and what we're going to do is What's
called the convolutional neural network
so we're going to take this same small
Network and apply it over and over
um and that's why we need the padding so
basically this two is computed by some
function of these three the 7.5 is some
function of
the next three the same function and we
repeat overlapping until we get to the
bottom okay so that's called the
convolutional neural network because uh
we're basically involving this function
uh with the input to get the next layer
and then we're going to repeat this and
the trick which is different here than
in most convolutional neural networks is
we're going to use the same uh weights
the same neural network here s to
compute each layer and we're going to do
this T times capital T times
okay
so this will let us it's just this is
called an architecture it's one type of
neural network you could have other
types and then but this architecture
will have some nice properties okay but
it's the architecture clear we the only
weights that you have to learn are the
weights of this constant size on neural
network here and then it's repeated uh
vertically and horizontally over and
over
and so that's what this sunn is and
um
why is it useful well I mean what can we
prove about it so one thing we can prove
is that even this simple architecture
I'm not saying it's the best one
um Can represent Turing machines so
suppose you had a turing machine M and
it has some a bunch of states and I'm
actually going to just for convenience
out let's let's assume the inputs are 0
1 and let's say all the states are even
numbers that'll make our life easy then
we can just add the state to the input
uh and basically this will simulate a
touring machine
um we'll pad the input we'll start with
an input we'll Pat it with a bunch of
zeros and then we need to say remember a
tree machine has a head we need to say
where the head is and what's written on
the tape of that place so we'll actually
add the state so the only one that is
where the where the head is is going to
be bigger than one
that's where the head is and the number
we'll add will be the state of the
turing machine so let's say the initial
state is two we'll put it here at the
beginning where the head is initially
then then we want to compute in the
standard way where we do the Tableau we
want to compute you know what's the tape
at the next period and that's going to
be the activations of the neural network
at this layer the first layer and you
can see that you know we need to figure
out of course where the head is and if
any of the bits on the tape have changed
which is a function only of the three uh
companies pre-activations so Jason and
that's why we have to pad it with the
negative ones that we know
if that makes sense
same thing and and we repeat for T
periods if the final how things state if
we call that zero then once once we hit
the helping State all the numbers will
be uh just zeros and ones and then uh we
won't even do any updates at all and
we'll just progress and T here capital t
is the number of periods that the turing
machine can run so as long as the turing
machine runs and completes and halts in
less than T steps this will be a
faithful simulation of the two
and so basically you can efficiently
convert any constant size turing machine
to a neural network that's also constant
sized
um but bigger
um
that will you know on any input which
the turing machine halts in time uh
let's say the runtime of the machine on
X is less than t uh this will give you
the same values
then there's you know you there's a lot
of messy details in this paper I have to
be honest um so I'm just going to try to
give you like a clean version in this
talk but I'm not going to go into all of
the the details like for example you can
do a lot of cheating with uh number you
know with very large numbers and stuff
like and you know just say we're not
cheating the weights that you know the
numbers we're using are all constant
size and in the weights of the neural
network and
um
this cannot be done
compare clean models for which you can
make the same statement how would you
range the return to genius but if we had
some
you know
and the graph of the plot of the power
for small values of the size like which
graph would would look smoother
and I'm just saying that you you look
for very clean models if you want to
extrapolate with small Behavior
empirical Behavior it's a small size to
bigger sizes so how does this range
do you want to do something from small
size so I'm not attacking that problem
so I'm not attacking the problem of uh
out of distribution learning where I'm a
training citizen when I put size and the
test set is in another emphasize that's
an interesting problem but
um we're just doing classic learning
where the distribution or input sizes
could vary that's a nice thing this will
work as long you know you could have you
could definitely have input sizes in
your tests that you've never seen in
your training set because your
distribution could be
what
in terms of how communities
I mean it's not I don't know how clean
you think it is but
um but uh it's it's very relevant
because it's a neural network so the
game of life like neural networks are
you know being used a lot and then just
has to create a descent so that's why
we're doing it this way is because uh no
network architecture is something to be
very rich about but I love the sort of
the general question
you haven't said yet
right
yeah so I was just going to ask like
do training algorithms actually find
networks that people like simulations of
Turk machines right right these are good
related questions so I guess
um I'll jump out right away and say that
I don't have like a uh a great algorithm
that that uh is you know awesome in
practice we have good for this at all
um this is an architecture a new
architecture that we're proposing
um
but you can prove that you know some
ridiculous algorithms work and it's an
open question uh to find a good
algorithm that works in practice uh uh
but um but a lot of these a lot of these
statements still kind of tell you
something about the limits of what's
achievable in the representation so you
know it's well known that neural
networks are like circuits so they can
compute basically any function and
that's useful statement you know if you
took a linear classifier it can't
compute every function so you kind of
understand something about the limit of
uh what a can and can't compute these
succinct neural networks which
um basically just uh they have a fixed
small constant sized neural network here
that's repeated uh in a convolutional
way so that this is the input tape you
repeat the small Network and then you
repeat that same thing layer by layer
and this computes the Tableau
so anyway so okay so that these are not
limited in the same way
um
foreign
I really don't think that this is you
know first of all I don't know like
three by one would be the best and also
I really don't think that a neural
network uh string machine would be the
best way to do this if you if you ask
the computer to optimize the weights it
probably wouldn't do it in a touring
machine style because the turing machine
is very limited where only one of these
numbers changes each time that's very
inefficient but if it could optimize the
weights then it could be much better but
whatever way to give you can simulate
the system
efficiently so in some sense it's
implicitly a turing machine yes
everything every one of these you're
saying can be simulated vectors right
right yes
but uh but the touring machine way of
doing things is highly non-parallel
whereas uh these convolutional neural
networks are typically much more
parallel so I would hope that if you
have a problem that was paralyzable it
would actually find a much faster
solution
um
now you're you're you mentioned gradient
descent You couldn't possibly do any
kind of gradient descent with this model
right because you're using how do you
compute the gradients you can do it um
so let me get let me do that now because
I think there's a lot of these questions
are asking about so how do we learn one
of these things well if you could learn
one of these first of all you could
learn algorithms so you've got the 16
network with a bunch of Weights which is
here which are not really coming out
um and I only have to learn against the
number of Weights which is good
um so just as a you know I said I gave
that weird seventh example but you know
multiplication is something a lot of
people are trying to get their neural
networks to work to learn where you know
the input is each input XI is a pair of
numbers and you know there's a product
that's really easy this in principle if
you could learn 16 neural networks I'm
not saying how then then that would work
um shortest path you could do all kinds
of cool problems where if your inputs
are graphs and edges
you can learn that from examples okay
um similarly as I mentioned that
smallest specs and factoring problems
you could learn as well as that steering
machine on average it was an average
case problem on that distribution you
could learn as well as
and parody functions not quite as I said
because uh we'll get to that later and
I'll just kind of uh there's a trick
we're going to need to do to be able to
learn functions that have like a secret
that's
um and bits long
um but as I've described it now that
that's not in the category of everything
you can learn and so
um you know what can we say again I'm
still like stalling on this question
which I'm not going to have a great
answer to of how we're gonna win but if
you could optimize over a small neural
networks then let's just notice that
that would work for learning so you know
in a sort of uh uh standard learning
statement you could say look if the if
the
um it's the network if the turing
machine has a small constant uh k and t
convey whatever it is then the runtime
of the chain machine then with high
probability over M examples drawn from
the some some arbitrary distribution D
over labeled examples
um
what you can say this is a standard
learning result says that the empirical
error on the training set which we call
error hat is close to the error on the
test on on future examples from the
distribution the generalization error
and formally that's just the probability
that if you ran this network with a
given a small Network s the probability
that's off compared to the error and the
training data and those things will go
down very quickly
um like one over root them okay so what
this means even forgetting the map is it
makes a lot of sense if you could
somehow magically optimize these things
it would make a lot of sense to try to
get low training error
and then if you did that if you could
get low training error this would
automatically learn algorithm all these
algorithms that we're talking about
that makes sense
so so the examples are actually
basically like parts of the
initial no so great question so they um
it's in that that we're illustrating how
to do the turing machine by uh showing
the internal States and the Tableau we
are just giving inputs and outputs
and we're trying to match uh you know
this function just trying to match uh
the outputs and if you could do that if
you could find the first there exists a
small uh
uh neural network s and then if you
could find anyone that that does such
that it does match the outputs then you
get a guarantee that it's performance
and future examples will be as good as
uh its performance on the training data
so therefore you know trying to minimize
your training error is a good way to
to generalize to Future examples this as
well as the best turing machine
um in this recipe I'll give them a
better position so it really it is going
to match the performance of the best
machine
and you do this by like this is
exhaustive search over all that good so
I have not I'm still installing my next
slide I'll have a teeny bit about that
but I don't know the answer
questions
so you're really wondering
at the beginning left is
you just want to find out actually what
should be the promotion exactly that
does as well as possible okay yeah
so there must be some okay because you
can simulate an arbitrary turing machine
an arbitrary turing machine can have
like arbitrary input also Behavior okay
um there must be like some some hidden
constant there that kind of like depends
on the Precision or something depends on
the number of states in the turing
machine it depends on the number of
states but then you're going to
[Music]
the the
where where you still have just these
like
oh do you need more
um hidden skates yes
the number of layers of this neural
network depends on the runtime of the
turing machine capital T oh no but how
about the just the players yeah I think
I need to pad uh it's a height we've had
it with a bunch of zeros so then I mean
yeah the size of s depends on the number
of states so if you uh yeah so then but
that's a bigger concept than the number
of states in the journey
so this dependence on T it means before
you build your Turing machines worse
neural net 16 records you need to know
yeah
you could have a neural net you could it
would be non-standard but you could
easily have an architecture where you
keep running until something happens
yeah I guess you couldn't do something
like that
um because this is a and I don't know
like whether that would be practical or
not but you could keep running until
um
configuration but I don't know yeah it's
a there's there's definitely room to
improve this is kind of the simplest one
where you have enough
optimization courses
yeah we assume that we know team or that
we're given an upper abundant T and then
you could do a meta search over
different teas if you want to no but but
if you just like you suggested do
something if you run until something
happens
you could run until something happened
if you knew the correct neural network
but when you get a bad neural network
then uh you run it it could just keep
going forever so you would need to kind
of uh
you would probably do that over example
it would get even Messier but I think
you could do something I think there's
tricks here right you might think
there's some things that are not but I
think it's possible to get a better
average version than this crude version
I'm doing the average case where it's
like you're giving it up around T what's
your best average performance but you're
saying no let's actually get something
which on some examples
between the mathematics Point of View to
a computer saying somebody pulled their
existed team they don't know right
you'll find it I suppose yeah
foreign
and the monkey is going to choose random
initialization for the this uh uh small
neural network and we can shoot I I
forget if it's from integers or
something but it's a small set you can
just choose these discrete
initializations from a small random set
and then I threw this in there to make
it look more practical but you don't
actually need it so in principle you
might also do gradient descent after
you've after the monkeys put its uh
weights down uh and uh that might make
things better I mean if you already got
the perfect weights that wouldn't change
anything but um you know gradient
descent does kind of magic like if if
people had said
just do gradient descent and large
neural networks and that will do really
cool things you might or might not have
believed them until it started working
um here uh there is a major problem
which is that the gradients
um are quite large you were asking about
this before so like it's a function you
can take the gradient uh and it's not
actually hard to compute the gradient
but they compile they they uh they they
kind of uh explode right the gradients
get larger like if you take a big step
if you take a big step in the direction
of the gradient the function is going to
change wildly but you could take a
really small step
if you take a really small step then the
function won't change but then you'll
need more examples so all the theory
says you only need a constant number of
examples to learn this thing I think if
you're going to take like small steps
you probably need a polynomial number of
examples
um will it work we have not implemented
it I'm glad I'm talking about it before
we implement it I know maybe it will
work I mean I I do have a a a a
reasonable justification for this which
is compare it to compare this to
gradient descent on a fully connected
large Network which has to learn
this computation which is polynomial
size so it has to learn all the weights
and the monkey has to get lucky even
luckier because it has to guess kind of
the initialization it has to guess the
whole circuit right and gradient descent
may help a bit but you're just yeah
okay but how the circuit depends on each
weight is actually simpler here you're
reusing the weights yeah there's a
computation there's a computation like I
didn't do the I didn't do the math here
but you can do you could do the
computation and it's not it's not it's a
standard uh relatively standard because
both convolutions and recurrences are
pretty standard and the way in which it
uh depends on all that like these
you can do the math either yourself or
there's automatic differentiation
libraries that will take the readings
for you and uh
okay so what I'm more worried about is
like numerical stability exactly and
that's what I'm saying about the uh
uh uh
I don't uh well you would definitely
need to take a small gradient step but
you're you're worried that even the
gradient itself will be way too large
yeah I mean this is optional but it's a
great question like I'm excited to
actually try to implement it and see if
this does better than you know what you
would compare well we know it doesn't
work where you have a huge circuit and a
huge neural network you randomly
initialize it it looks nothing like the
function you're trying to learn and then
it does its best to generalize and it
kind of works but not great or
um in some cases you know yeah
there's there might be some Advantage
there might be some hybrid one uh which
is in between where you get some benefit
I don't know just make sure you
understand so you're saying that the
standard the second part of the slide
this would be like exponential in the
circuit size
exactly exactly because you know you
have to guess a circuit right for if you
have it's ridiculous to guess a turing
machine for multiplying members but it's
even more ridiculous to guess a circuit
now I can't prove uh it could also
potentially use GPT somehow I don't know
you could try to do something smarter
for sure
um but
um but basically uh I was trying to be
careful here I can't prove that this
thing uh won't work for regular neural
networks but for sure the same proof if
you try to do the same proof approach
and you say the monkey has to get lucky
the monkey has to get really lucky uh
with circuits and with what regular ones
my hope is that you know
um you don't even have to choose integer
initialization you could choose some
continuous ones
do radiant descent and maybe uh it'll
work at least as well as it does down
here
so in fact I was thinking about your
vitamin is it why random initialization
I mean Randomness but the question is
whether it's totally random or something
that's related to the primary try itself
exactly exactly and that is
exactly
exactly and they have like there's a lot
of papers that
um try to learn how to initialize neural
networks well across problems and they
like I still don't know why that works
but it sort of works
um exactly this way you'll know the
structure
there might be some Randomness that will
dive well with the problem itself if
so yeah if you did this a lot it's just
I mean basically it's another way to
write a program but not in a programming
language like python which gpt3 can do
kind of well
um but in this weird uh neural network
representation which maybe computers
could also learn to do different code in
Python which is kind of amazing why
couldn't they write it in this other
numeric format which might even be more
intuitive to them because or I don't
know you know it's more numeric so
yes
is there is
a process associated with this like
along the lines of the uniform
distribution over circuits is an
interesting object
to to search there's some
non-negligible probability that when I
draw a uniformly random uniformly random
circuit and do that repeatedly maybe I'm
covering this case in circuits well
enough to
are you when you say a random circuit
are you think of the circuit s or at the
circuit for the whole I'm thinking about
the circuit test one circuit and then
um
has anyone tried like de-randomizing
this hypothesis so if we have circuit
over balance then maybe we can go around
initializations
um well yeah for sure they're not
initializing actually randomly right
when they initialize their leverage
their pseudonym
because they have
but but they're they're not I don't do
so there's this lottery ticket
hypothesis right because which seems
related to this
um as anyone looked at de-randomizing it
to say if you have approvably secure
pseudo-random generator and you assume
the lottery ticket something like this
could actually work pretty well
foreign
so I'm looking at the statement of the
theorem and I think I don't understand
what it means oh yeah sorry it's not
very clear it's not very important first
of all so what I'm saying is uh we're
going to pick a random initialization
let's even drop the option and reading
the same thing for a second so if we
just picked a bunch of random
initializations and for each of them we
saw how close is uh the output of the
neural network to where this circuit has
to uh with this small uh sorry a small
neural has to
um
to the labels that the labels that we
have through the training center that's
why it appears and we see which and then
we do this a kind of number of times and
we see which one of our s's all right
random initial s's gave us the best fit
to our data
um with high probability one of them
will match the best turing machine of uh
with a constant number of states and the
force
that makes sense and so yeah I guess the
question it's like how many you need to
pick as a function whatever so if you
want to get uh if you want this to work
with probability one minus Delta I just
did a webcam if you want to work with uh
with probability one minus Delta for any
Delta then you need to order the log one
other Delta well okay but
that's again like the hidden constant
involved the number of states in the
dream yeah yeah is it just exponential
or is it oh yeah well you see if you
have a dream machine then then you might
need like an S squared yeah it depends
on how exactly you represents your
turing machine if it's just like one
state goes to one statements but it's
basically like you'd expect it to write
down information
so does the step size
appear in the statement of the theorem
because that says reading descent yeah
no so for the theorem Let's ignore this
optional thing maybe I shouldn't put
that in there so
that's our optional but let's say we
let's say the step size is zero so we're
not degrees we just pick a random one so
the theorem is that it's a monthly
effect it says if monkeys keep guessing
small small uh networks it's it's uh
basically encompasses it's at least as
large as the set of small two emissions
okay so there's there's this is a very
easy here so the monkey's really the
star of the show yeah definitely
um sorry so this is a trivial Theory but
you know it still may be interesting
or maybe we could use some other smart
initialization like Jeffy was saying GPT
or something uh
so uh there's also kind of uh
is is confusing when you think about uh
what to do with it in this this model of
learning so it's a bit different than
the standard pack learning or agnostic
language so
um so basically uh we defined a model of
it's not pack learning we have to define
a new model probably a pathologically
optimal so basically uh we're saying
it's our probably a practical Apple but
also we're saying that a learning
algorithm is nearly optimal instead of
comparing it to classifiers which is way
pack learning diagnostic learnings we're
actually going to compare to learning
algorithms because like a classifier
like a neural network could be huge GPT
has 175 billion parameters the
pollinators now that's 520 billion
parameters the code that they they use
so it's very small like the amount of
codes
is much smaller than the neural network
itself so it makes sense to compare
yourself to some short learning
algorithms rather than uh are
classifieds does that make sense yeah
exactly so we're defining this
um which I don't think has been defined
but maybe not good
it's very natural so you one subtle
point I guess is you're comparing the
error of your algorithms on the
validation data to adjust the error of
the
learning algorithm
um we get bonus validation data which
you can use we need that we can't do
this without bonus validation data we
can't just train our algorithm on the
same training data and say we're doing
as well as the best algorithm but if we
give ourselves a little bit of extra
validation data then we could I mean
again you could this the the algorithm
for the first Slide the terminal
algorithms programs we work here based
on the numerate algorithms
when you talk about error you're doing
the actual error and not error on the
trade exactly future error and
generalization
so this is another trivial to achieve
Thing by picking random Journey machines
or random programs running them uh all
the ones that you know completed and
then taken the one that's best in the
validation data and we've improved
trivially that that will achieve this
sort of uh probably approximately
learning for and then we Define it for
it this is just uh we're doing it in
this case they're all sewing machines
but this notion might be kind of
interesting in general as a complement
to pack learning which is for agnostic
women which is usually defined for
classes and functions so I do understand
what a a is it traditional yeah so in
learning there's like a confusion
between terminology typically where
there's this notion of a classifier and
a classifier I think of as a neural net
the thing that's doing the
classification there's a learning
algorithm which outputs the classifier
yeah sometimes we'll call that one yeah
the training data is input it outputs a
classifier which is yeah
instance
[Music]
and they are just like only like fuel
relations and function is interesting
yeah we're taking we get
um we get uh it's not shown on this side
but we get the training we get training
data from the true distribution so we're
using real world data for training so we
assume that we have problems from some
distribution of problems that we care
about so they have such things kind of
things we've got a bunch of problems
from that distribution and want to do
well on future products from that same
distribution if we had to make up at
this area going if we had to make that
part of the problems
um then maybe it wouldn't even cover
anything interesting
um so and this is a generalization of
fact learning can show that if you can't
alert capital in a family of uh
classifiers then this thing uh which
learns the algorithms should uh in
particular include the algorithms of
backgrounds that family so it will do as
well as that and uh
um so kind of you can draw a picture and
say okay in the world of classifiers
um there's all classifiers in your
family
um there's them and then you can draw
the accuracy of the y-axis the
bayesians they call it the most accurate
classifier but that's ridiculous we've
never been able to optimize over all
circuits
um so then there's the ones that are
output by algorithms efficient
algorithms and uh that's a smaller set
and so we want to just compete our goal
is to get accuracy uh near those near
the best efficient algorithm which is
still super hard but as I can illustrate
here these are programs for learning
they're much smaller than a program is
constant size and they're much much
smaller than specifiers
yes
um but I'm I'm so happy that I didn't
have enough time to go into all the
details because it's a mess
all right so um okay that's just a
formal version of what I did there
before and then
um okay so the trick for learning a
parody uh or any uh learning problem
where there's a hidden uh concept
um again that's not a constant sized
machine but uh fortunately uh Abe and
send them there's a nice very beautiful
paper they had where they showed
um something really surprising for a lot
of us so how many people here know what
statistical queries are
so um uh yeah so you know you can't
learn parodies with statistical queries
and uh yet uh they've proved that you
could actually learn parodies with
stochastic gradient descent which is a
standard way of training learning
algorithms uh on a training set if you
have a very uh specific in the
hard-coded learning algorithm in your
circuit but um so the surprise was that
everyone thought that um neural networks
were a statistical query learning
algorithm that you could approximate the
neural net gradient update by uh just
you know averaging a retaining set and
shouldn't be that sensitive and the
whole catch the funny thing with
stochastic gradient descent does is it
works one an example at a time and that
does actual magic a statistical query
algorithm doesn't get a labeled example
one labeled example at a time it only
works in aggregate whereas stochastic
gradient descent which we thought was we
thought oh stochastic gradient descent
is just a speed up of the algorithm that
you might want to do which is run over
your whole training data average the
gradients and then that would be a step
um but actually stochastic grade in The
Descent is in some ways more powerful
than this averaging algorithm and that's
that was what they showed is that
actually you can learn uh parodies if
you do stochastic gradient descent
um their algorithm will bake into the
weights of the neural network
uh uh gaussian elimination the algorithm
or whatever algorithm you need to learn
the problem so it's kind of a cheat but
not real but it still makes this point
um I still think these these uh results
are are useful because they help you
understand sort of limits of what things
might be able to do and uh it definitely
changed my perspective on what
stochastic gradient descent is it's not
just this is query algorithms
um okay so uh they and you know
fortunately I don't have time to really
show you the details of how that works
it's ugly but you know it has some math
and it's like what's connected and what
are the weights and what are the edges
and everything
um and actually my edges aren't even
showing up but basically for our
construction it's it's simple I'll just
talk architecture so the architecture of
the neural network it doesn't have to
implement their particular trigger our
particular architecture just says
instead in addition to this team defog
repetition of this small uh convolution
and uh the you know the layers we're
gonna have one additional layer which
you can kind of think of like uh well
it's just one layer and uh it it's got M
it's m by n times n large so it's got
room if you need to store all the
training data uh okay so that's um
that's how big it is and uh and then uh
it'll actually have an extra t0 at the
end and then there's edges between here
and
um
there's a bunch of edges and they you
just start the with weight zero on them
and so the architecture is you start
with this uh network with a bunch of
edges of weight zero and then you have
this repeated thing and you can prove
that that uh is capable of representing
uh if you do surpass the gradient
descent uh in our construction the way
it might work which is probably not the
best way but you couldn't memorize it
will actually memorize the inputs uh in
the labels in the weights of the neural
network in some kind of crazy uh process
and then uh and then run the learning
algorithm once it's seen all M inputs
so I definitely don't have time to go
into all the details so basically you
know um there's a few things here that
might be interesting one is this idea of
instead of thinking about pack learning
uh thinking about competing with
learning algorithms
so family of learning algorithms which
you could actually not just neural
networks you could think about that for
I'm trying to learn
your you know old school svm with a
kernel in a bandwidth a parameter if you
have a single parameter there and it's
pretty easy so you can try to learn as
well as the best learning algorithm in a
family and it could be any family
um
um in general uh and that's that's what
this point is you want to learn
algorithms in general there's a trend in
machine learning to learn algorithms
rather than just classifiers so we kind
of went up one of that stretch which is
exciting I'm curious if there's anything
you can say and collect complexity
Theory
um you know where wherever you might use
enumeration in your proofs you say well
that I used to think that was ridiculous
and just a you know a crutch that I
needed to prove my theorem is there some
possibility that you know I could use a
intelligent language model language
models to train them data or something
to make it seem much more plausible or
is it could be a theory of these things
uh I think it'd be really interesting
and you know we give a particular
architecture here which is recurrent and
convolutional and I think we really need
to try it out and see if it works better
for these algorithms problems than uh
is
[Applause]
any questions
so yeah actually about this slaps the
like our recurrent architecture in
addition to this so I was thinking sort
of to or to solve like what chappie was
saying where you have too many layers
you could with if your hidden stick was
like one additional thing
that you just write to once I mean
because you know when you're in the
Haltom State as you slide that window
you could just put a one on that and
then
Define your architecture if you want
that you know pulse the recurrence Yeah
by uh just saying uh the number of
repetitions is not fixed in advance but
you just keep going until you see one
somewhere or some number that's very
close to sometimes that and then uh stop
at that point and it's maybe a bit more
like I think it's like a bit more
natural to think about because it
doesn't like
the number of layers is whatever is
inside that small window but then just
like how an RNN they don't follow every
recurrence
right yeah you don't think of these as
separate layers so
questions
[Applause]
foreign